تم الترحيب بمدرب سباحة كبطل
بعد أن أنقذ منافسًا من الغرق
في بطولة العالم ،
ولدى سكولز كل التفاصيل
الرائعة التي يمكن رؤيتها شخصيًا.
أظهر ما فعله المدرب أندريا
فوينتس وهم رائعون ، ألقوا نظرة على الأمريكية أنيتا ألفاريز البالغة من العمر 25 عامًا ،
فقد أغمي عليها خلال روتينها الفردي
وغرقت في قاع المسبح ومع
عدم رد فعل رجال الإنقاذ على الإطلاق ،
فقط غطسوا لإنقاذ ألفاريز
في الواقع ، قفزت سبّاحة أمريكية
أخرى أيضًا للمساعدة بمجرد وصول
فوينتيس إلى السطح ، أصبحت فوينتس هي نفسها حاصلة على
ميدالية أولمبية أربع مرات
وقد أخبرت صحيفة إسبانية
بعد ذلك أنني قفزت إلى الماء
لأنني رأيت أنه لم يكن هناك أي حارس إنقاذ
قفزت للداخل وشعرت بالخوف قليلاً
لأنها لم تكن تتنفس ، هذه في
الواقع هي المرة الثانية التي اضطرت
فيها فوينتس للقفز لإنقاذ ألفاريز
وأغمي عليها  قبل عام ، في
حدث التأهل للأولمبياد ، تلقى ألفاريز
عناية طبية بجانب المسبح قبل أن يتم
نقله على نقالة تم نشره
على إنستغرام لاحقًا بأن ألفاريز كان في حالة
جيدة وقد ينتهي به الأمر
بالمنافسة لاحقًا في البطولة ، إنه
أمر رائع للغاية لرؤيتك نهاية سعيدة